depuis dimanche dernier les dérapages
racistes pleuvent sur certains réseaux
sociaux notamment ceux des grands médias
on n'a pas les ressources pour effectuer
une modération complète de tout ce qui
se dit sur la page radio canada info il
y en a plus de 500 mais l'abonné se
serait il y aurait facilement du travail
pour dix personnes à temps plein le
journaliste aux réseaux sociaux à radio
canada vincent groupe on va vraiment
ciblé les publications qu'on considère
le plus à risque de dérapage est
évidemment mais quand il ya des
événements comme celui de dimanche va y
en a des dérapages
on en a constaté beaucoup des trucs
comme ils auraient dû en tuer plus par
exemple d'aider des gens qui
applaudissent déjà qu'ils vont félicité
des trucs épouvantable tout cela
contraste avec les témoignages d'appui
public notamment des politiciens
canadiens au ministre du québec cette
semaine est venue rappeler que les mots
ont un poids une vérité qui ne semble
pas peser bien lourd sur la conscience
de beaucoup d'internautes ya pas une
relation direct de cause à effet d'un
type décrit la violence mais un imac ont
construit et un climat de stigmatisation
généralisée à chânes antonius et
sociologue à l'université du québec à
montréal
ce climat légitimise c'est un discours
très hostile qui lui-même légitimise un
discours plus directement haineux et qui
mènent à la violence docking série une
sorte de chaîne d'enchaînements ou où le
discours devient de plus en plus
radicale et ils l'amènent à ça le
service de police de la ville de
montréal a lancé un appel à la
dénonciation des propos racistes et
provocateurs sur différents sites web
c'est lorsqu'ils deviennent haineux que
la loi peut intervenir mais dans
l'espace entre le mépris et la haine
on ne peut rien faire sinon attendre
d'une personne par ses propos puissent
provoquer un passage à l'acte de
violence
autrement la charte canadienne des
droits et libertés garantis la liberté
d'expression alors vouloir du mal
la haine c'est vouloir du mal et on a
créé cette infraction justement pour
pouvoir encadrer des propos de personnes
publiquement c'est pas des conversations
privées là qui ferait en sorte de de
provoquer
justement un passage à l'acte suzanne
coupal est une juge québécoise à la
retraite par la charte canadienne on a
vous irez on a dit on la garante si
cette liberté d'expression ont la
garantie mais pas jusqu'où alors là il
ya la limite raisonnable
évidemment c'est lorsque l'on voit
visées des groupes particuliers en
raison du sexe la religion de leur
ethnie
on détermine qu'on ne peut pas concentré
une attaque qui sent que d'un cas
d'aujourd'hui ce soit les musulmans on
ne peut pas concentré une attaque
provoqué vouloir provoquer une haine à
l'égard de groupe particulier en raison
de ce très particulier bon peut-être
qu'on pourrait peut-être aller regarder
ailleurs ce qui se passe les
responsables des médias sociaux sont
interpellés mais aussi les médias de
masse et les messages populiste des
politiciens au lendemain d or et
d'attentats bien évidemment l'or est un
peu au consensus
paroles vertueuse et erronée dans
quelques jours quelques semaines
quelques mois le ton pays que compte
avoir d'un milieu politique n'a pas de
sections vont revenir et certain
emmanuel choquette et analystes
politiques et chargé de cours à l'école
de politique appliquée à la faculté des
lettres et sciences humaines de
l'université de sherbrooke à une
centaine de kilomètres au sud-est de
montréal souvent on a l'impression que
les politiciennes les une chose en
campagne et l'état et agissent autrement
mais c'est pas long que tout à coup il
ya un écart qui se crée entre
l'impression on est à côté de ce qu'on a
promis est évidemment trop mal à ça peut
créer des tensions les tailleurs la
population sait que l'élite politique au
delà mise à la presse a récupéré peut
perdre des plumes au profit de certaines
perspectives plus démagogiques les
propos méprisants et racistes sont comme
des arbres dans une forêt ils empêchent
les citoyens devoir de mieux comprendre
et de séparer limites de la réalité
nous avons laissé de rhétorique de haine
se développer le spécialiste de l'islam
noman rabaudy professeur adjoint à
l'école d'études politiques de
l'université d'ottawa dans la capitale
canadienne
on a sous-estimé et on a pensé qu'elle
faisait partie de la liberté
d'expression alors que c'est un
détournement de la liberté d'expression
cette rhétorique elle a créé l'idée est
elle l'a fondé son discours sur cette
confusion qui est la source de tout les
malheurs que nous voyons maintenant
entre islam et islamisme
faites attention cette confusion là elle
est en train de faire porter à l'islam
les dérives et les crimes et la barbarie
de l'islamisme radical
il s'agit de deux choses différentes
mais personne ne voulait nous vous
l'écoutez voilà le et voilà le résultat
malheureusement un reportage de radio
canada international